hello everybody my name is markiplier  and welcome to five nights at Freddy's I  understand what I need to do I need to  watch the cab so that they don't come  after me oh hi I need the last till 6  a.m. oh god if I gotta have enough power  oh god I'm never gonna make it because  go away get this crap job I could have  gotten more money washing dishes  somewhere what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] ok  why do I have to go through 6 hours and  s crap why did I come back for another  night  he's gonna kill then I get cornered I'll  punch it straight in the Gabba swear on  me mum mom everybody so little longer  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  if I didn't want to stay the first night  why would I stay any more than five why  would I stay any more than duello on the  Internet don't let them talk down to you  like that let a gentleman oh I will  enjoy my kuester dead end